how about combating actual acts of
racism how about singling out racism and
then actually doing something about it
as opposed to doing this kind of marxist
news speak in which we go through
everybody's hidden actions you know I'm
sensing I'm sensing a real sort of
underlying I don't know racial bias to
this whole segment Robert I find you'd
be racially biased I find you to be
insensitive bigoted misogynist based on
everything that you said it may be
hidden maybe I can't detect it but we
all know it's there so perhaps you
should go through this program at the
end of the program you will feel free
you'll feel better about yourself
over the topic of uh institutional
racism is brought up you'll always ask
uh where is the institution show me the
racist laws that we can fight them
together correct
um
Red Line welcome to Alabama
this would qualify as a racist
institution the state of Alabama
[Music]
so now I go back to the question that
you say that you answered which is show
me the law you've named an institution
you don't like now show me the law no
it's not an institution I don't like
I've lived here my whole life but I mean
you called the racist so I assume you're
not super yeah it has flaws
um to say the least but um
the constitution of Alabama demands that
schools be segregated by race if it
weren't for the federal government the
Liberals literally want to segregate by
race I remember for like my high school
graduation all the black kids were like
different different stuff and there's
nothing wrong with that they're doing it
they are doing it in some places there
are some colleges where there are
lounges and classrooms only for colored
people no whites allowed that is insane
and the fact that that they want to go
backwards to separating people by race
that's gonna that's gonna punch them all
in the face if that keeps you know
that's gonna that's gonna whip back and
it's gonna hurt I remember Tate said in
the video that um white people get more
backlash from liberals than black people
get from conservatives or more yeah we
don't focus on Race period I'm gonna go
kill the dog I'm not joking there would
only be white people in this room
I will admit to you okay so a couple of
a couple of fundamental assumptions okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna admit I have not
read the constitution of the state of
Alabama so I don't so I don't know the
provision that you are talking about I
will assume that it says what you say it
says for the purposes of this
conversation if in fact there's a
provision in the state law of const of
Alabama that says that segregation is
mandated by law of course that's racist
that's Jim Crow and that would be
institutional racism the point that I'm
making is that there are a lot of black
people in this room today because the
institutional racism that you are
decrying was in fact wiped out at the
legal level by the federal government in
the 1960s so if you're citing a law from
19 you know from 1873 or 1865 whenever
the Constitution embedded segregation if
you're citing that law to prove
institutional racism and that law has
not been applied for 50 years you're
going to need to do better yes that's
why I said he's going to mention
redlining like dude obviously that was
messed up but that's like those years
ago you know it doesn't matter right
it's been overwritten it's it's illegal
it and it hasn't been enforced it
doesn't matter that is not institutional
racism and nobody knows it exists maybe
a handful of people do and more people
know now that he's out there screaming
about it but you're making a problem
where a problem doesn't exist go solve a
real problem you care about black
communities get in there do something
about it it really is it it really is so
true though white people get so much
more backlash from liberals for being
white than black people get from
conservatives for being black it's so
true we get more we get more backlash
for being white from other white people
than we do from black people too it's
absurd it's too bad for the black people
don't even care they're like they're
like what are these white people making
up all these problems for yeah like The
Logical look at the interviews look at
the interviews when they go in and they
ask them about this stuff they're like
this is so stupid put these Karen's out
of here leave us alone race place and
that all that what happened to swastika
but you can't wear the Halloween costume
you want unless no one finds it
offensive
well now the selectively offended get to
run the rest of the country I mean this
is what we are creating we are creating
a society of panty waste fascists what
we are creating is a group of people who
are oversensitive to everything that are
willing to call the cops as soon as they
are offended it's actually incredible
and it's a violation of the First
Amendment which you saw with a professor
from the mass communications department
at Missouri telling reporters that they
have no right to be there and at Yale
you have students shouting people down
if this is the climate that we're
supposed to create do you remember that
there was a professor yelling at a
student reporter for being there and
saying you get out of here you don't
have you have no right to be here so an
actual Liberal Liberal Professor
smashing the right of Free Press in the
United States they couldn't be reported
so that is fascism that's what fascism
is and they call everyone else fascists
but you're [ __ ] on Free Speech
[ __ ] on the Free Press saying these
these things shouldn't exist what do you
want to you mind why do these people
want to go backwards to that why would
anybody want to go go to that and you
know you were any Halloween costume you
want to wear period I don't care like
somebody can wear there were things I
don't like but I don't care if somebody
wears that Halloween costume
I showed you the picture it was the dead
prom queen like somebody's gonna come up
to me and be like my grandmother was
murdered on prom night you know like
whatever I'm sick of it it's just made
up problems I get so mad about made-up
problems yeah at the end of the day
that's all it is they just want to keep
you distracted on these ridiculous
problems imagine spending this much time
on your problems and that's why you
can't pay your student loans because
you're not focusing on building your
life how can you honestly stand up here
and say that you support abortion you
support government intervention excuse
me you support government intervention
to uh make abortion illegal which is
designed to kill someone and yet you can
stand up here and say you don't want
government intervention for guns which
are also designed to kill people because
guns are not designed to kill children
guns are designed to kill bad guys if
operated by a proper person there's not
an abortion in the world that doesn't
end with the death of a baby
[Applause]
the question in Hobby Lobby is freedom
is being infringed upon employees
freedom is not infringed upon when they
enter into a consensual relationship
with an employer that includes certain
types of Health Care consensual of
course it is who is forcing them where
is the gun where is the gun who is
forcing them where is the chain who is
locking them with the gun language
no this is the reason that I use the gun
language is because it is vitally
important for people to understand that
every government measure at the end of
the day has it must be compelled by
force that's what government measures
are for there is a vast difference a
huge difference in terms of personal
Liberty and freedom between the
government compelling behavior and a
company saying that we are not going to
provide certain types of coverage and if
you don't like that you can quit or buy
your own coverage there's a vast
difference
thank you
the gun's the whole issue
the question was about abortion and I
just wanted to know why exactly do you
think a first trimester fetus has moral
value okay so a first trimester fetus
has moral value because whether you
considered a potential human life or a
full-on human life it has more value
than just a cluster of cells if left to
its natural processes it will grow into
a baby so the real question is where do
you draw the line so you can draw the
line at the heartbeat because it's very
hard to draw the line at the heartbeat
there are people who are adults who are
alive because of a pacemaker and they
need some sort of outside force
generating their heartbeat okay are you
going to do it based on brain function
okay well what about people who are in a
coma should we just kill them decided
the problem is anytime you draw any line
other than the Inception of the child
you end up drawing a false line that can
also be applied to people who are adults
so either human life has intrinsic value
or it doesn't I think we both agree that
adults human life has intrinsic value
can we start from that premise I believe
that sentience
um has is what gives something moral
value not necessarily not necessarily
being a human alone okay so when you're
so when you're asleep can I stab you
I'm still considered sentient when I'm
asleep okay if you are in a coma from
which you may awake can I stab you
well then uh no I guess not you're like
I'm glad you answered that because I
have no interest in action that's still
potential sentence and it's still a
potential
sentence
being a fetus oh he just he just hit him
Checkmate the saddest thing what I was
gonna say is when there's a baby at like
six months being aborted I've seen like
doctors talk about it where there's a
baby being aborted at six months and
then in the room over there's like a mom
trying to save her baby at six months
because she can't physically hold it
anymore so [ __ ] up I mean that's
horrible it's heartbreaking like my dad
was born at like he was born what at
like six or seven months and he had to
be an incubator for a few months bro
could have just died I wouldn't be here
so Sunny fast and mom wouldn't wouldn't
be a thing right now yeah I just don't
like how the way people talk about
abortion they just talk about it like
it's like a form of a concert like a
it's like the same thing as like the
Plan B of contraception and I I think it
right I don't want to get into how
whether I feel about abortion except to
say that I wish that we just had a
different culture around it and it
wasn't used as birth control and that we
had a culture of adoption and love and
self-restraint and selflessness because
it really takes a lot to say yeah I'm
going to keep this child and I'm going
to raise it and I'm going to be a good
parent it's also a risk but it's a
beautiful thing too you know once you
have that child there's nothing but love
so if you really have a problem where
you know you really can't afford a child
you have to really be more responsible
to begin with we shouldn't be killing
millions millions of babies every year
how many pop it up how many babies are
aborted every year I want to see it and
let me tell you something about safe
spaces there's only one group of people
one group of people who want safe spaces
that are race specific they're only one
group of people that want safe spaces so
they never have to hear from anybody of
a different ideology or political
persuasion those people are called
fascists okay you've got a bunch of
fascists damn fascists on this campus
who are trying to shut down political
debate and trying to cloister themselves
in this little Cocoon of stupidity so
they don't have to debate anyone or
think about issues outside their kin so
they can feel comfortable guess what
life isn't about feeling comfortable
life is about bettering yourself get off
your ass you stupid pansies common Ben
Shapiro W holy how do I get the internet
have a can I buy a t-shirt with just Ben
Shapiro's face on it that I can just
walk around and wear and it's a what
about me and on the back I wanted to say
get off your ass your you stupid pansies
can you make that for me for my birthday
got you okay I'll put it on a mug I'm
someone that believes is certainly the
child unborn child has rights I believe
that the mother has rights I simply
happen to be a person and some belief
that those mothers rights uh deem to
usurp those rights
any of my rights allow me to kill
another human being there's only one
thing
could make me say or do anything
I need is on the ground they have to
whine and cry about it on a national
level so in the name of free speech
foreign
you can't run ads within a certain
period of time your public financing
versus private financing those are rules
around an election that is completely
different issue than the government
saying randomly you can and he can't
invest in businesses
so you're conflating those two issues
that have nothing to do with one another
why so let's just uh
why me because those are because hey you
know you believe in education
because it's a free country and I get to
spend my money wherever I damn well
please
um I personally don't think that like I
could have I'm gonna go murder the dog
real quick I wish you could just learn
to grow with the flow man an abortion
just because morally I feel like for
myself it wouldn't be the right choice
um but how do you defend your opinion as
a white well-off religious man
um how do you defend your hat like
telling a woman what she can do with it
because evil things are of course evil
even if I'm a white well-off religious
man and good things are so good even if
I'm awake
he's making it worse than the dog by
getting angry the government to do the
right thing now I don't understand why a
piece of legislation makes them better
at what they do I mean the government is
not very good at what they're doing now
why did why does a new warding make them
not suck because part of the reason
[Music]
[Applause]
part of the reason you have a law or
initiative as a deterrent that a
government won't even be involved that
the bad guys won't be going to gun shows
to buy guns so they have to circumvent
fat guys are buying guns like benches
are you an absolute [ __ ] who is this
guy gangbang is it going to the gun show
to buy their guns okay yeah the mob
Mafia yeah they go to the gun show let's
take away all the guns let's take away
all these bad guys guns you know what
they just had there was just a stabbing
in Canada we should take away knives I
think knives are to kill people we
should also take away words and dirty
looks because those hurt too
that's exactly the point if bad guys are
not going to gun shows to to with regard
to Ebola and for a second this is the
mild digression with regards to Ebola
the federal government just made the
case that they don't want a federal
travel ban right because they said if
there's a federal travel ban people will
just find a way to circumvent the
federal travel ban
Ana do you see the analogy here
Smith I just wish some days when I hear
some of this that the sun would just
explode and and just end it all just
take the whole galaxy out we've
and we just haven't the light takes a
long time to travel that would be great
it takes like four minutes so from the
Sun to here yeah what'd you think it
took I don't know a long time no it's
like four minutes fact Checkers pop it
up I want to know this myth is
inherently better for an economy than
saving it's only true if you're talking
about somebody's actually taking the
cash and just shoving it into their
mattress banks are in the business of
lending when they take the money in they
don't just stick it in Al Gore's fake
lock box they actually lend the money
back out to people to actually create
new businesses and new products you had
an investor right when you started tyt
you were given four million dollars by
Buddy Romer to start tyt that's great
that's the way business should work
right but that money had it didn't come
from a bunch of poor people buying
hamburgers it came from a very very
wealthy guy who gave you money to create
a business a lot of people want to
patronize if you want better products
and better Services you need more
investment in the products and services
the basic name trickle-down economics
hmm
the basic name trickle-down economics is
not something that any conservative even
proposed it's a leftist revision of what
economics actually is because you're not
giving me the money it was my money in
the first place created through
voluntary transactions that I had with
others I've not stolen money from either
from anyone neither have you and the
idea that money has to be forcibly taken
from you and hand it to somebody at the
bottom end of the economic spectrum to
somehow jog the economy McDonald's but
it's not going to jog all of the
creation of the products and services
that make all of our Lives much better
today than they were 30 years ago in
terms of the stuff we have access to I
seriously don't understand the logic
behind these leftists wanting more taxes
like let's give the government more of
our money like why do you like paying
taxes and they're crazy they [ __ ]
everything up so they if we give them
more money then they can fix it yeah
okay they won't [ __ ] it up more one
thing I learned in business is that the
tighter of a budget you work with you
ultimately work with like that budget
better and you don't spend money as
recklessly and you ultimately get more
done as weird as that sounds if you give
someone a bunch of money they're just
like oh we'll try this we'll try this
it's a lot better to have smaller budget
and work with that and be really
strategic in what you do and try to find
methods to Market organically and do
stuff like that it sounds insane to say
but giving like a new company millions
of dollars like they're gonna [ __ ] it up
all right Ben Shapiro's rating one to
ten one hundred one hundred that's the
highest one I got an 11.
all right Charlie [ __ ] yeah I've got
like a like a brain crush on superhero
yeah
make sure to join the Discord in my bio
my University drops this month going
into all of my social media knowledge my
mom is making a section on how to be a
gentleman how she's raised me to be a g
I've raised him to be a gentleman and
how when he's not I just slap him upside
the head yeah the first thousand people
to sign up get in for thirty dollars a
month dirt cheap and then from there it
goes up exponentially so this first 1K
spot is going to sell out very quickly
so make sure you're in the Discord
staying tuned let's get you done let's
get [ __ ] done all right guys
[Music]